thank you
foreign
yes it's the time change I'm going to
say we're 52 minutes early
but with that division three uh work
session is going to start
um the initial topics for today is uh Mr
Wieters who runs it for DH HHS is here
today we had three items from hb2
conversations that we wanted to get some
details on from him one was a little
over 20 million on mmis the other two
were both Consulting and then if he
comes up with the fourth item we'll talk
about that but then after that I intend
to go back to the hb2 document where I
think the last one we finished was uh
item 253 so we'll pick up at 254.
and then Mr Ripple has prepared a sheet
that summarizes all of the Departments
it's hb1 and hb2 requests isn't it
the one that I have here is hb1 only but
I can print out the handful of requests
that they had for husband too as well
okay
all right
yes
were the five bills on tap for today too
or is that something for the future
they're scheduled for tomorrow
afternoon tomorrow afternoon okay
we we should we should probably caucus
just to make sure that I remember what
we've agreed to yeah they just want to
make sure where we are thanks
Tuesday March 14th at 10 No 1 o'clock is
on the house calendar
yes sir
right for the bills it's one
okay so so Mr Wieters why don't you come
on up
Mr White you're welcome to come as well
and then
um
Mr Ripple you're better at remembering
this than I am what which of the hb2
items are we talking about when we talk
about the 20 point x million for mmis
that is section 235 on page 80.
okay
okay I see it and the and the basic
thing is that we're trying to pull
23 million excuse me we're trying to
pull the money from the 23 Surplus
all right go go ahead dude I I think you
listened to some of the video last week
did you just want to start talking or do
you want me to ask you a question to get
it going
I did listen to the recording from last
week so I can try to address some of the
questions that you had that Nathan
deferred to me if if that's your request
Mr chairman that that'd be great it's
it's still early in the morning for me
okay
um just for the record my name is David
Wieters Information Services director
for Department of Health and Human
Services
So based off of the questions of what is
the 20 million dollars 20 million 531
625 that was in hp2
that is associated with our process
um in this current biennium where we
submitted the operating costs for the
Medicaid management information system
or mmis at
um in hb1 for the current biennium that
as a result of the legislative process
was pulled out of hb1 and put into hb2
as a one-time cost for maintaining and
operating that system
alongside there was an hb25 component
that supported the Capital Improvements
for the hardware and software that we
have completed
so there's two components that are at
play here and for the 24 25 biennium we
again submitted the operating costs
which the total costs of this system is
about 45 million per year
of which we get 75 percent federal funds
which equates to about 10 million
dollars a year
of General funds to
support that Medicaid management
information system so let's let's pause
for a moment certainly and
um Mr White do you what what what page
in hb1 is the mmis money that Mr Wieters
just referred to
924 I see
8009 Medicaid management information
system
I see Zero people
I see total source of funds and 22 as 35
million
and in the next two years 175
000 a year is that accurate yes that's
correct
Okay so
listen listen to Mr weeder's uh bef
before the hearing
hb2 thinking that was one time money and
that we left a smaller maintenance tale
for operations and maintenance basic you
know
simple updates not up there was there
it's about 45 million dollars a year or
per budget Mr readers who is it per year
or per two-year budget 45 million
so
um in state fiscal year 24 it would be a
total of 41 million dollars it's 9.7
General funds 9.7 million General funds
and in fiscal year 25 it would be a
total of 45 million dollars uh 10.8
General funds
okay so I'm gonna I'm gonna actually go
over that one more time 24 what should
the bottom line be for this account
yeah
just asking where this is so we can
follow along that's that's what I'm
trying to do I think we're on page 924
and I'm talking right now about the
total source of funds which is about 40
percent of the way down that page on 924
right now in 24 it says 175 188
what what should the real
operations and updates
not upgrades updates money B and 24
total
so
um
so it would be approximately 41 million
two hundred and ninety nine thousand
seven hundred thirty dollars two I'm
gonna put it 41 3 just to keep it simple
for me
um and then what is the breakdown and 24
of that 41-3 between Federal and general
so the the general funds would be
approximately 9.7 million
and the the federal would be
approximately 31.4 million
okay let's let's have the same exact
conversation for 25 then yep so for 25
the
approximate total would be uh
45.3 million dollars total funds and
then the split the general funds would
be 10.8 million dollars
and the federal funds and safe fiscal
year 25 would be
34.2 million dollars
okay
so so so saying what you just shared
with us
this uh as a the hb2 item for 20.5
million
that is basically the general funds for
24 and 25.
yes that that's the combined General
funds and then you'll also see in that
hb2 language there's a provision to
accept the federal funds
um without fiscal committee approval and
so those other federal funds so just one
thing at a time just stay on the money
for a second yep
um
okay now so this is uh this is a
financial technical question
can can we have the 9.7 and the 10.8
reflected in hb1
and still have it covered by these 23
funds
so there are two issues I want there I
want I want to roll forward any money
that we had intended for this project so
that we can use it in the next fiscal
year
but
but I also want to start getting our
operating money looking right for future
division threes so Mr Ripple go ahead
well I guess I would start with a
question for the Department which is
oh sorry do you have an idea of how much
you would lapse from this account in 23.
we don't anticipate any laps out of this
this is um the funds that are here they
pay for fixed contracted costs each
contract has a fixed price limitation so
we don't expect much of any lapse coming
out of this particular account
so I don't think there's any money here
that you could roll forward from 23 you
could find money elsewhere in the budget
and Roll It Forward from 23 for this
purpose
it's a little more complicated that way
though
thank you
but it's already here I understand what
you're saying
it's already here being rolled forward
from 23 right
well the governor's
the governor's budget spends it in 23.
so I think what representative Edwards
has suggested is is spending it in 24-25
which wouldn't necessitate carrying
funds over from 23.
isn't that what we're doing
it it it is what we're doing with hb2
yes sir what what is causing me to be
perplexed about the whole thing
is that
my assumption for the last two years has
been wrong
I thought that the money that we put
into hb2 last term was one-time money
what I have been shocked to find out
today
is it the total amount of money that we
spend on operations and maintenance
which includes updates not upgrades but
updates
hmm
is a lot
you know and I I and because it was so
much I had assumed it was an upgrade
cost that was one time
so initially I was pretty comfortable
with having
this hb2 item here because I thought
this was still
uh upgrade money and and so I just
wanted to know the history of it that's
that's how we got into this the the the
the the problem is now there's this huge
operations tail
that I think needs to be an hb1 because
that's proper accounting
and I don't know how to do that go ahead
one possibility maybe this won't work
but one possibility is just to put in
the section 235 note the actual numbers
that and reflect that it's for this much
in 23 and for this I mean in 24 and for
this much in 25 and then put in the hb1
a note that says
this account is currently being budgeted
in hp2 this year so that people can see
both sides of that coin if they look
backwards I don't know if that's
possible that's legal to do but I think
what I heard you just say and it sounds
right to me and Mr Ripple you you be the
judge of this is that we can footnote we
can keep the numbers low
in in the hb1 and just footnote it to
say that the funds are coming from this
hp2 item and in the hb2 item we could
write this with a little more Precision
to show how much is going to each of the
years and that this is really operations
and maintenance as opposed to
um upgrades and that way whoever does
this next budget will have a better idea
when they look at the historical record
yeah I think you could do that and that
way you could continue funding it out of
the 23 Surplus in House Bill 2 you would
just make it clear that it's for
operational costs in 24.25
okay so this is the first time I think
we've talked about footnoting anything
at some point we're going to probably
spend time a day or something looking at
footnotes
I don't know that you have a a full day
to look at footnotes but if anybody has
um any concerns with footnotes or any
interest in particular footnotes that
you'd like to amend or take out or add
by all means let me know and I'll I'll
add them to the the tracking sheet that
I'm about to hand out later okay the
only footnotes I'd like you know
highlighted would be those that have
changed if we've got essentially the
same footnote from last budget to the
current budget then I I'm okay just
assuming that that makes sense but if
we're changing a footnote you know
particularly around lapsing and
non-lapsing I I think we should probably
consider it do you have a question go
ahead
then my question is really for Kevin I
think
um
two years from now
what is this page going to look like is
it going to look similar to the way this
one does now with it a
a big chunk of money in
I guess it'll be in 23.
that's a good question I I think it
probably would look that way I think if
the funds even if you add a footnote to
this accounting unit if the funds
themselves are not reflected in 24 25
the house bill one side will be lower
and the house bill there will probably
be a house bill 2 component of it as
well
okay well I just wanted to try to figure
out and there won't really be any way
for the next people I mean hopefully
some of us will still be here and we'll
remember this page and
everyone will remind us of it but there
really wouldn't be any way for someone
just to open the page
and know what had happened
I think you might see if I take a look
at the governor's budget you might see
the old footnotes so if a footnote is
added oh no you don't see the old
footnotes okay
so you're right there really wouldn't be
anything but but whoever the LBA will
see the footnotes
where do these those footnotes live when
they after they've been used
uh I'm not sure they they just don't
appear again in the next budget but we
would have the history in form in the
form of the detailed change sheets that
we produce
and the budget compare reports so we
would be able to see it
okay no that that answers my question
thank you representative and then Paul
thank you
um I just want to clarify one thing
you said the capital budget covered the
upgrades are we talking about the
pre-major upgrade that you just
completed in maybe a month or six weeks
ago or something
thank you for the question yes that the
about a month ago we completed the
hardware and software upgrades utilizing
the essentially 24 million dollars of
the 90 million dollar capital budget for
mmis life cycle replacement
and was that 24 million dollars
appropriated in the current budget cycle
right
that is correct thank you
my hearing faded
would you did you just ask that the
money that just got spent came out of
hb25
yes okay
and the answer is yes the money for the
major upgrade major upgrade came out of
HP 25 capital budget yes okay that's my
question I think that when you and you
agreed with that I think yeah if I can
clarify
um because just make sure because we're
looking at two different components so
that the 24 million dollars for the
major hardware and software upgrades of
this of the current mmis system was
funded out of hb25 for the current
biennium and we did complete that work
last month
but the hb2 items for this biennium was
for the maintenance and operations and
so there and that the challenge is the
numbers are pretty close like there's 20
million versus 24 million so they can
get really confusing really fast
so just to call back so that last part
was in the HB it was like just like this
note we have here with two section 235
there's a similar section in the last by
any or the current biennium is hp2
spending the 20 or whatever was a
million dollars for the
ongoing maintenance contracts is that
that is correct thank you
thank you Mr chair I guess
sorry for being late to this entire
discussion
is there any reason we can't long term
in this process move it over to hb1 so
it's really clear and transparent
I entered the room at that point when
you were having that discussion
can I try that and and then if I get it
wrong then you can correct me and I'll
have learned something
you and I agree that would be preferable
the challenge with it is
um
I like having that huge amount of money
paid for out of surplus from fy23
and because of that objective it
primarily has to live in hb2
what we're talking about is making sure
that we footnote hb1 so that these
artificially low numbers
have a little bit of an audit Trail for
future future division threes to
understand that
operations and maintenance is an hb1
item and one-time projects are either an
hb2 or in this case hb25
did I get that close
yes okay
so in in the words of our former House
member and finance member of a long time
former representative Allen Court
what was his comment for German version
of a shell game
um that he used to say what I'd like to
see is a footnote in hb2 that says we're
going to move this money from 23 into
this category so that we have the paper
trail from 23 with the excess funds to
push it over and then in 24 and 25 show
that it's in the correct category is
there a way to do that so so again we're
in violent agreement so before you came
in I guess we talked about having this
hp2 language
augmented to be more clear what we're
doing and why we're doing it and how
we're using it
correct and I'm okay with the hb2
language saying we're taking 20-ish
million dollars whatever the right
number is and we're moving it out of 23
excess revenues and we're putting it
into this category but making sure that
in the budget for HP one and two sorry
hb1 424 and 25 it clearly shows what
we're spending so
the novices on next the next budget
cycle who are on finance can see the
paper trail
one thing that happened a few times two
years ago is there were a few sections
in house bill 2.
that made components
of the HHS lapse non-lapsing carried
forward into the upcoming budget and
treated as restricted revenue for the
purpose of funding something specific
you could do that in this case you could
make approximately 20.5 million
of the HH of what would otherwise lapse
non-lapsing
and treat it as
restricted funds for use in the Medicaid
management information system accounting
unit and then it would show the numbers
would show up in there and they would
effectively be funded out of 23 Surplus
so the good news is the HP one
audit Trail will be clearer and easier
to follow in in better shape next time
division three looks at this in two
years
the to the extent that there's bad news
there's got to be some there's got to be
some bad news here so so what's the bad
news
I don't know that there's necessarily
bad news it does get increasingly
complex if you try to do this
across multiple topics on multiple
issues I guess if you're confining it to
mmis it's pretty it's pretty simple all
right right now I'm just trying to
confine it to mmis because I I still
think we're cleaning up my mistake from
two years ago where I thought this was
one-time money not operations and
maintenance money and so we got to get
the books looking like reality I think
go ahead
thank you Kevin that's very helpful
um just of the committee does anybody
have any major heartache about doing
what was just proposed by Mr Ripple in
terms of documenting this funds left
over from 23 or moving over to 24 as
restricted use funds non-lapsing so that
it can be better accounted for in the
next budget cycle in terms of
transparency
representative walner
is that
are you okay with that
when we get past this I I do think that
works but when we get past it I have a
couple of questions I want to ask about
this area
Mr chair I would propose that we ask Mr
Ripple to do that just for the
cleanliness of next year's budget cycle
I I like a clean budget cycle so we've
discussed two alternatives on how to
handle this Mr Ripple are you clear on
the second one
okay represent walner
if we're past that can I ask a couple of
different questions
um
this account seems to be going up fairly
rapidly I mean in it looks like your
actual expense in 22 was 35 million
and in I think I just heard you say by
the time we do all these transfers and
everything it's in 25 it's going to be
45 million
and that's a 10 million dollar increase
and I know a chunk of that is federal
but what is called why is this going at
this rate and how often do we
renegotiate the contract
thank you for the question so I'll
answer the second part first but we this
contract is a five-year contract with
the option to renew for another five
years if we so choose and get up and get
approved through government executive
Council the so where are we in the
contract cycle right now we're ending
year two of of five
so we'll have three more fiscal years on
this contract
um before a renewal would be requested
the contract itself was re was renewed
for that five-year term to allow the
department to go through a
re-procurement of the entire Medicaid
management information system following
CMS guidelines for modular reprocurement
we are about we're two years into that
process of the project
in terms of answering a question of how
it's moving up
the the cost to
um provide there's many components of
the system and it can get pretty
detailed but the there's one component
where any provider should be able to
query the system to identify if their
claims are being processed and being or
are eligible for processing there's a
cost for every time they do that
transaction those costs have gone up as
more providers come online as well as
the
the cost to maintain and operate the the
changes in the legislator from both
federal and state to maintain the
programs or making augmentations or
enhancements to the system which then
increases the maintenance and operations
with couple examples is
as part of the 21st century cures act we
had to add another function for any
individual to be able to go online for
self-service portal to see the claims
that were processed on their behalf
that cost additional money it was an
additional enhancement to the system
that is costing us a little over a
million dollars a year to maintain and
operate
um
our goal with the re-procurement effort
is to do a couple of things one is to
get better competitiveness for the
solutions that are out there like
provider management claims management
financial management data warehousing
and third party liability
and with that with that goal is to see
if we can drive the costs down from that
competition perspective and also build
um
A system that CMS will continue to
support our enhanced 75 maintenance
Federal fund match
we don't we don't know what those costs
will be historically what we've seen in
other states is that the modular
reprocurement is actually increased cost
due to the Integrations that you now
need to do between multiple vendors
but there are some states that the
there's five or six or seven contracts
resulted in the same vendor
and but it was still competitively
compute procured and did Drive their
costs down so it's it's trying to figure
out as we go through the procurement
methodology maintaining our compliance
with our federal Partners guidelines but
trying to see how we can drive those
costs down
so if I understand all of that what I I
guess what I got out of it was that
it's a contract
but
this contract actually is in a contract
for an exact amount of dollars at the
beginning of a contract because you're
buying you may need more services during
the contract period is that
am I
getting that correct my apologies the
contract is a fixed cost for each year
or year over year but there's a
year-over-year increase based off of
inflation and anticipation we do have
what's called enhancement pool hours
that are included in the contract to
allow us to do those enhancements and
it's only if we go above and beyond our
existing contract language that we would
do a contract Amendment
um I'll give you an example we plan on
submitting some Amendment to the
existing contract to support medical
coding
um in in the near future
to the governor executive Council for
their approval so as new things get
required of us to be able to adhere to
federal reporting in this case this is a
federal requirement then we go through
and we do we look at the contract and
see can we do it with the existing
contract scope or do we need to amend
the the contract and find additional
funding to support it
so the so the metaphor I use on that is
like if you were to go contract to have
your roof replaced that would be a fixed
price because they'd be able to bid in
everything into it but then as they
start to do the work you go oh wait a
second let's do some gutters on that too
and then afterwards you go you know
those gutters ought to be those fancy
ones where no leads can get in each of
those is an upgrade opportunity that you
get dinged on the contract and that's
that million dollar example that Mr
wieders provided earlier yeah
and one more and this one you're going
to give me the explanation and I'm going
to get oh sure I knew that
so I see the actual expense for 22.
I see that we're moving over
this 20 million dollars to make 24 and
25 work
where is the adjusted authorized for 23.
I I believe because it was an hb2
provision the the the budget system does
not show those figures here and Kevin I
don't know if you have better insight
into that
because the appropriation was made
through the house bill 2 process which
is part of the challenge that we're
talking about here yeah okay so that so
there's exactly where it happened this
time also okay yeah thank you
represent nordgren did you have a
question okay a representative Hull Mr
chair and and this last point is exactly
why I'd like to see some of this I
recently saw an advertisement where they
were describing well the state didn't
spend any money in the budget and that
was how they phrased it although we
spent millions and millions of dollars
by Framing that it wasn't spent in the
budget it hides these things and I don't
want that behavior to continue so by
forcing whatever we can over into hb1
even if it's non-lapsing restricted
Revenue type stuff that helps make sure
that in the future that doesn't show up
that way
Kevin did you have a response to that it
looked like you were wanting to talk but
I didn't have a response to that but I
did just want to comment that I I'm
pretty sure there have been instances in
which funding in-house Bill 2 as well as
other bills has been reflected in the
adjusted authorized figures but that's
not something that
the LBA or the legislature has control
over it's something that would happen
within Das so I guess there's no
guarantee as in this case there's no
guarantee that a house bill 2
appropriation would show up in the
adjusted authorized figures
foreign
specifically in hb1 with language in hb2
to drive it there right then Das doesn't
have the ability right they would be it
would be tracked naturally correct I'm
saying as a straight general fund
appropriation it wouldn't be guaranteed
to show up in the adjusted authorized
is that true just for clarity for any
other funds within hb1 and hb2 if we
didn't let's just say hypothetically in
hb2 there was a 500 000 allotment for I
don't know Christmas trees for everybody
and would the as have to put that in
I think typically you would expect to
see it if it's an ongoing operational
expense so as I think this this through
now I'm wondering if it's because it was
labeled as a one-time expense in House
Bill 2 the last time maybe that's the
reason they didn't put it in here
thank you well that was exactly the
narrative because I that's what I
thought was the truth after we had
hearings like this I thought that was
the truth that there was a one-time
wedge that she'd go into hb2 and it was
in retrospective
45 million dollar mistake but um
okay so if we do can I go back now
I just want to make sure I'm I'm
tracking where we're at if we put this
into HP one just like we said then we'll
put a there's restricted money that will
go to it to pay for it in hb1 for 24 and
25. what what happens to
235 what some kind of a rewrite right
it would be Rewritten we would say that
the department
the department would be able to carry
forward 20.5 million dollars into 2425
and it would be treated as restricted
Revenue in this accounting unit for the
purpose of funding mmis
representative yeah thanks I I just I
wanted to ask a couple questions
related to the provider you say you're
designing or implementing provider
systems that's part of what the software
packages are are you integrating to
um to the providers directly or are you
trying to integrate with software
vendors that may provide billing support
systems for providers already or how how
does that work
I can get the details but I don't know
the exact details but I do know the the
goal the provider management module for
all most of the states out there is that
it's a vendor-ledge solution for the
providers to connect to but they don't
have interoperability with their systems
primarily because of different
legislation regarding privacy and
Security in every state
but I can certainly follow up to get a
more detailed answer if you need it
okay thank you
so technically I think whatever we're
sending out to the providers is some
sort of a thin client that comes from
the the application and that there's no
integration at the provider end just
available use of a Thin Client that's my
guess
trying to stay at a high level what the
way the providers interact with our
system right now is they start off by
submitting an application an actual
digital application through which we we
consume and process their application
and then provide them a provider id in
which they can submit their claims and
do claims eligibility
um
requests through an electronic data
interchange or an EDI transaction so it
is a digital interface for them to
do the claims processing of Eligibility
and then submit their claims to us for
processing on our system but it's not
integrated with their system so they
they actually have to do that component
of submitting
their data through like an FTP or file
transfer protocol type process
and follow up go ahead
um and um for dual eligibles is that
CMS medicare Medicaid is that built in
or is that
a single I would have to get back to you
on that okay thank you
all right I think uh I think this is
officially Beat to Death so are we ready
to are we huh
beats alive uh let's let's go over to
the two Consulting hp2 items what what
numbers are those
okay are these these are two separate
things with some common questions
and the common question is this this
basically says that you need some help
and I believe it
but it doesn't tell us where this help
is going to be applied in terms of which
projects which Commissioners priorities
that sort of thing
foreign
thank you um based off the conversation
on Friday and then following up so
starting with the section
245 on page 81 that 1.5 million dollars
for
essentially it's for project managers
and business analysts for the for the
following projects and so those projects
are Incident Management System that was
really really meant really meant to
support the intake of any type of
incident from for dcyf or children of
children youth and families the New
Hampshire hospital and public health
they have totally different needs and
business requirements but we found that
we can build one solution to be able to
manage like a New Hampshire hospital
where they might have a spill in the
hallway that they need to report in how
someone react to Public Health needs to
have the ability to track incidents as
it relates to their working with um
with the public health networks where
they're saying hey we have a problem
with the disease surveillance system we
want you to resolve this bug and then
with dcyf they they work with their
providers where they might do restraint
and they have to report that restraint
to dcyf and all the components so that's
one solution with multiple different
like perspectives
but we're trying to to do that as a
concerted effort so that we don't have
three different Incident Management
systems and three different maintenance
and operations costs so that's one of
the projects the other the other five
projects are Housing Services for mental
health
environmental health management system
for Public Health
data analytics for Behavioral Health so
further furthering their data analytics
so that they can have informed decisions
and then the automated federal reporting
for Medicaid so there's a there's a
current report but many reports that we
have to send either monthly or quarterly
to our federal Partners in many cases
their manual Excel spreadsheets with
access databases our goal is to put
those into our Enterprise basis
intelligence platform to automate that
and reduce potential human error and
time to deliver those reports and then
the the final one is external and
internal secure data portals and what
that is is we have an external portal
for our public reports and we have
internal portals for our non-public
reports that are securing the
information but we need to further
enhance those and so what that 1.5
million does is essentially a pro it
gives the department the ability to
Leverage
um I call it like a Headhunter contract
where where we could
um Outsource the Consultants bring them
in train them through our security and
privacy best practices as as team
members to work on these different
systems
the average rate on the current contract
that we're actually going to be going
out to RFP for another one the current
contract is about 125 an hour so that
results in twelve thousand dollars over
the biennium
um for those for those project managers
and business analysts across those those
projects those are a list of the
projects that we would be targeting
however we would anticipate that we'd be
able to pick up other projects as they
come on board
and they're really targeting two
platforms our Salesforce platform as
well as our Enterprise business
intelligence platform
so to anticipate our discussion in two
years
is this is 245
is this one time a one-time set of
projects or uh I I I listening to you it
sounds like uh the projects will be
worked and kind of feel like one and
done
but the capability of being able to do
this kind of business process
re-engineering and Alignment is probably
an ongoing function or mission of your
department and I'm I'm sort of asking
because I'm I'm trying to figure out
should this really be an hb1 item it's
showing up as an hp2 item
that is a good point I mean our
long-term goal is to prove that this
solution can work and actually deliver
projects on time within a budget and
meet the business needs
um and then the the goal would be if
that's something that does work that we
would be submitting as an operating cost
in the future but I think we're really
in partnership with doit which is that
second section
um we're trying to prove out the concept
that many private sector organizations
have done where they Outsource these
resources bring them in to do those
quick hit projects and then let those
people go and only bring them on board
when you actually need to do the design
development and implementation
um the other component is to leverage
this to operationalize into our existing
doit infrastructure and DHA test
resources so from a maintenance and
operations perspective
our goal is to leverage our existing
staff to maintain and operate the
solutions but bring these Consultants
ins to do that enhancement the big the
big push for new Solutions on the
platforms
okay so I want to separate a couple of
things with whether you use Consultants
or whether you use in-house staff to
provide the opportunity to do the
business process re-engineering and the
whatever you're doing on the uh you said
Urt user interface team or something I
don't I don't know what that acronym
means but
my apologies was Department of
Information Technology is what I meant
to say doit I I slurred my letters
together all right when I have bad
hearing okay so whether you you're doing
it through contracts or through
employees is not the issue I'm looking
for here the issue I'm looking for is is
is is is this truly intended to be
ongoing operations and maintenance and
therefore something that should be an
hb1 or is this what I thought I heard
you say for a moment a a kind of a
business experiment to see if this adds
value and if it if it doesn't add value
we won't see it next term if it does add
value you'll you'll be proposing it in
hb1
foreign
to address the business experiment
component that we do know that it will
add value in the sense that we do not
have the staff currently to be able to
achieve any of those projects on time or
within any legitimate budget right now
um and it would be taking our current
platform forward to be able to address
those projects effectively
but the reason why we didn't submit we
submitted this initially as I prioritize
need to our HP one budget because it was
above and beyond our current budget
and as a result of that looking at it
saying well we have six targeted
projects that could be one-time project
deliveries
that I believe was a discussion of why
why I was moved into hb2 leveraging 23
surplus funds it is entirely possible as
you as you indicated Mr chair that
we would look at that into the next
biennium and say we really do need this
as an hb1 item to support the business
needs on an ongoing basis in the sales
force and the Enterprise business
intelligence platforms to continue to
deliver new projects as they arise and I
would fully anticipate requesting it
again in the next binding budget so so
if we have a high expectation that the
answer is yes I I this feels like an hb2
item except that we're trying to use FY
23 Surplus
sort of my summary did you have
something representative walner
I just wanted to know if is there
Federal matching fund for this
yes there are
um so for for Section 245
it is a 50 50 match
um
I'm sorry page number
let's see here so so page 81
245. Mr chair is there a corresponding
budget book page on HP one that we can
see where this would have gone
sorry I didn't mean to interrupt no no
you're right that's what I was trying to
get to is where where would this be on
hb1 if it were in hb1 sure let me just
grab it
so
it would have been
or two
it would have been on page
1089 it's accounting unit 59 52.
give us a second so we can find it
all right could I just ask what is the
other is
47 also 247 also matched with federal
funds are both of those
so these aren't
1.5 million dollar projects these are
three million dollar projects
so there is there is also a federal
match
um
see I'm just doing some quick math it's
closer to
um approximately 66 percent General
funds 34 federal dollars that we're able
to leverage for that particular
Initiative for the second one yes
okay so I'm on it took me a while I'm on
one page 1089 and and then where on that
page
so it would most likely
um if it were to be included in hb1 it
would uh most likely be on the
subsequent page in 1090 within class 102
contracts for program Services
um and or it could also be budgeted
within Consultants
okay so if we if we just were doing
dealing with this
then the total source of funds instead
of being
56.085 would be three million dollars
more just to account for HB 245.
and and the split is split on the 245 is
50 50. yes 50 50 on the 245 and then on
247 it's approximately 66.34
okay
so and and and Mr Wieters on on 247
this is related to the hiring I.T
Consultants to develop and Implement
automated Solutions
this sounds extremely similar to 245
is it is it the same deal that you
you're choosing to contract this out and
uh because we've got some money
available and you can go contract it out
rather than hiring in-house you're
already convinced that this wants to be
an ongoing part of your capacity
are you not
to I think you have two questions
maybe three or four in there maybe three
or four so the two that I heard was one
is it looks very similar to section 245
and the difference is that this is for
the technical Component Resources so
data Wranglers sales or Salesforce
developers Salesforce Architects and
data analysts so it's rounding out the
whole team to be able to deliver these
different solutions it is the same
projects as representative Wallner
indicated earlier so it's a combined
solution but they needed to be submitted
as two separate items because one would
be a is really doit expenditure or
information technology expenditure the
other is a Health and Human Services
expenditure to have one complete team
and if I got this second question right
yes our goal is that
in in light of not having additional
staff added to to the um to the state
both the uit and DHHS to do this then
our alternative is to Outsource those
solutions to Consultants so so I
understand Outsourcing support the need
to do that I but it comes back to the
conversation we had earlier with the
representative poll had some opinions on
this is that we we really ought to get
hb1 to reflect ongoing operations that
then the question gets to be if it's an
hb2 item strictly because this gives us
an easy vehicle for spending Surplus
from from the current fiscal year I I
would prefer
another alternative to getting it into
hb1 and still leveraging 23 revenues if
we can go ahead just one point of
consideration so so as Dave had
indicated earlier this is a prioritized
need and it's the first time we've ever
done something like this so so this is a
new model and this isn't in response to
the some of the labor challenges that we
have had so
um I I don't have an opinion one way or
another but but I just I just want to
make that clear that we've never done
this we assume it's going to work that's
why we're doing it we don't necessarily
know if it's going to work but our
assumption is it will
um and and so it is a new initiative
um for for this biennium and we've never
we've never engaged in this specific
type of model so
we we don't have any real reason to
think it'll fail either the corporations
do this all the time they go out and
Outsource to augment their staff in a
temporary basis you know but but the but
the ongoing requirement to be able to do
these sort of things is will last as
long as we use I.T I think that's the
argument for finding a way to put it in
hb1 and the strongest argument for
keeping an hp2 is because it's an easy
way to spend down 23 Surplus
so what what I'd like to do is just ask
you guys who are you know the experts on
on correct budgeting how how do we get
these expenses reflected in hb1 and
still spend HB
23 money or excuse me FY 23 money this
is the same thing as we said on mlmis
that we would just direct restricted
funds somehow
um you could do that again I might
suggest not doing it repeatedly for all
of these Appropriations
um in fact in in the case of these two
specific Appropriations because they're
because they're so much smaller
3.5 million over the biennium you might
be able to just fund this out of 24.25
if you were so inclined
I I think I'd prefer that I just would
like to keep the books clean and and one
of the things that representative Mooney
asked me on offline that makes sense
um is it would be nice to see all of the
projects for which we're trying to take
FY 23 Surplus and spend it in the
24-25 does such a list exist somewhere
or would that have to be built
separately
well the summary she yeah the the
document the representative tolersky has
I had sent out a house bill to summary
sheet that included general fund
Appropriations across the three years so
if you still have that if not I can I
can print out more copies it shows
everything that's currently funded in
fiscal 23.
okay I I'm horrible with paper so I
dated March 2nd and we got it via email
and then I think we got a hard copy of
maybe a little bit after okay what was
the document titled
um hb2 was introduced sorry Health and
Human Services related sections I'll
print out some hard copies now
three
fiscal year Columns of allocations
so representative norgren what what what
are your thoughts on this am I making
too big a deal out of putting stuff into
HP one for visibility and continuity do
you do you share my concern that we get
stuff out of hp2 and keep it in hb1 if
it's an ongoing
budget item
I just think
whichever way I think we would defer
them from the HHS to see how it works
for them and with Mr Ripple
okay so because this is a prioritized
need that didn't get picked up by the
governor and we're talking about it here
I I I think you could assume just the
general level of support
the issue here is is having hb1 be a
more meaningful document to the next
division three by putting stuff in there
that belongs in there what what are your
comments on that
from my perspective I I I mean we have
hb1 we have hb2
um there are certainly challenges
um as representative hole indicated
earlier when you're trying to understand
you know what are the costs associated
here what are the costs associated over
here
um I I would probably defer to the
committee as as that that really seems
to be a policy question
um I think my priority is making sure
that we have the money to do what we
need to do
first rule of resource management is to
acquire resources representable
so this one and a half million in
sections
245 right
240 yeah 245 247 for the 1.9 million
do you anticipate that that will be an
ongoing annual expense
if we put it into the budget right as a
one but it's a one-time
make changes
that
ramps up the budget unnecessarily for
the following year if it's if it truly
is a one-time expense
even if it's labor as a one-time expense
that's different than if it's going to
be ongoing could could I try responding
to that
Mr chair
which I responding to his question go
ahead
so I think what they've been saying is
this a new approach I want to try for
doing some extra development there's
always going to be a need for extra
development
if it works out that this extra
development methodology works
the next cycle when they still have more
new development they would put into the
budget as new development but it'd be in
the budget and yes it probably would be
an ongoing expense going forward it
might vary in terms of dollars it might
not always be fixed like you would for
for other areas of the business model
but I think that's what I heard them
trying to say
thank you for summarizing it yes
representative that would be how how I
would answer the question
and if I could just add if we're going
to keep it in hp2 which actually I'm not
a versa doing I would kind of see the
descriptions of the projects in hb2 just
so we have I I was I thought it was an
excellent presentation of what they're
doing with it I'd like to kind of see
that in here so other people so when we
sell it to the house they can we can say
this is what they're doing with it
oh
just so I'm Mr chair go ahead
representative I would agree with Mr
Earth that
Representatives
whoever you are today
um that that we tread so the public
knows what we're doing and we don't just
have it a line item in the budget so I
think that's important to be transparent
I
I agree with both of you that that would
be better than what hb2 does now I I'm
just finding myself obsessing on wanting
to put
ongoing operations and things that are
going to be budgeted next cycle
into hb2 when they feel like they want
to live in hb1
and respond so I guess my point there is
they've done it this way for an initial
approach
I think making it transparent in hp2 is
actually better for this initial
approach
next time it needs to be one let them
come and sell to us why remember it's
just going to be numbers in HP one
come and sell to assume presentations
how they're going to sell that to us at
that point in time
just a suggestion
I believe I heard
Mr White say it could be under Section
hold on 046 for a budget right
Consultants is one of the options for
some of this
or contracts for program services but if
it's under Consultants
I'm on page 1090 right if we put it
under the that portion of the budget it
becomes clear that this is outside work
that is short-term in nature that is
right and now the justification for
future Consulting needs to come back
next year why do I need right what other
programs am I doing
did I hear that correctly
um
so so yes we we would most likely
budget that uh in in in the future in in
a in a 102 if if those funds are
provided
yeah
102 or but what's the difference so
for my understanding what's the
difference between 046 category and one
102.
right
so generally speaking most a large
portion of our contracts are are
budgeted under 102 you'll also many of
the conversations we've had
um we we also have mentioned the class
74 for the those sub-recipients we use
Consultants less frequently normally
it's for very kind of limited services
and we use that more in the it realm you
won't see that line really used in any
of the other program areas as as those
areas more so have like your traditional
cost reimbursement contracts
oh yeah
representative
I think
not sure he's done yet
so just one of the other components is
there's a transfer to oit
um line item in that same I think it's
on
class 27 line 27 there so in there when
we when we put it through the doit
budget when we do that transfer they
actually have a a class line detail and
we use class 46 for the Consultants on
that site so like as Mr White indicated
the when it comes to the 1.95 million
that is in the hb2 that would normally
be in the transfer to oit
and then budgeted in class 46 to hire
Consultants the 1.5 would stay in our
class 102 for contracts because of the
way we we go out and get the contract
and then we would have it in class 102.
so my understanding was 102 was
allocated when we're hiring somebody out
on the outside to deliver a service to a
person and I maybe I would I
misunderstood I was thinking Consultants
are delivering services to the
department same as like the doit side
it it could be used either way
representative
that's okay I just wanted to comment now
that we've this document you guys have
seen the 2023 expense there's
it's not like there's a laundry list of
things that we haven't seen yet I think
we've already discussed last week and
this morning the items that have 2023
funds so
um I guess we're talking about the mmis
issue and then
um what's on page 81 are the only two so
I guess it's it's not a bigger
ball of yarn
do I have that correct okay making sure
and it's clearly not a bigger ball of
yarn
great
thanks so so I I I think we've uh we're
done because we've spent as much time as
this is worth and in conclusion
I think that it may be just less motion
if we leave hb2 item fundamentally these
two hb2 items fundamentally alone other
than providing the extra detail so we
can take Mr weeder's Project list that
he read verbally and include it so that
there's a better audit trail of what we
we bought this cycle and so then when
they come back in two years to whoever's
in this room they there there's there's
a little bit more history that we can
follow
representative you'll agree with that
okay representative nordgren you agree
with that okay
do you have an issue with that Mr Ripple
no nope okay so those were your three
things Mr Wieters did you have a fourth
thing that you wanted to talk about
I do not at this time thank you
uh so thank you for coming by
uh and I think we're gonna
continue
where did we drop off on this uh Friday
on on page well it's item 254 I believe
go ahead are we done with Mr wheaters I
I think I just excused them too I just
want to say thank you very much um the
presentation was very Illuminating um it
left a lot it put a lot in that was left
out last week so I appreciate you coming
back thank you thank you for having me
thank you for going through this process
I appreciate it
um
all right who Mr Ripple do you want to
walk us through 254 sure so 254
appropriates funds to support Family
Resource Center infrastructure it's a
million dollars each in 24 and 25.
can can we I need a basic education what
what is exactly a Family Resource Center
is that's probably defined in law
so I I can
um if it's helpful I can as we go
through hp2 and if there's any other
questions I can have the the program
area come down and provide you all the
information you'd like on that tomorrow
um but but I can definitely follow up
with a very clear explanation I don't
want to bungle the answer all right
that's that that's an email with a
sentence okay a Family Resource Center
is defined as and then whatever the
specific definition is would be great
email works and I you know I think I did
have a a stray fourth question from Mr
Wieters
you st you're still here right you
haven't checked out on us just yet
okay this was something that came up
over the weekend
uh dealing with e-verify and whether or
not the new heights system already had
the capability to process eligibility
using e-verify as a confirmatory Source
do you know Mr Wieters
so
two answers to that question one is
e-verify it as the e-verify.gov we don't
go through that but we do do address
verification and we do multiple threads
of verification for the integrated
eligibility but we are looking we are
still seeking out through the
that specific New Heights team to see if
we go to e-verify.gov to address that
but we do everything that e-verify.gov
does through our other third-party
contracts for address verification and
um
I would say we we leverage Federal
taxpayer information to make sure that
we have the right taxpayer as well as
our Social Security Administration feed
to ensure that we have the right Social
Security information so we we do
multiple Avenues of verification for the
new height system oh okay so I want to
make sure I understand precisely what
you're saying that
if we took all of the population of New
Hampshire that's running through
New Heights
doing all the verifications that we do
for eligibility we would come out with
the exact same results as if we had done
that in e-verify because they're the
same checks
I would have to verify that statement
I have an inquiry out with the team and
and I should have an answer by the end
of the day for the for the committee
all right thanks uh representative hole
if if it's fair game to ask questions
right I have a question regarding
um time sheets and what is captured
within the IT department side of things
is there
and if you're not the right person to
ask this please say so is there a
current process in place to allocate the
3100 employees time of which roughly 3
000 are hourly to what projects they're
working on
already within the system yes so we have
a federally approved we we call it a a
pay cap it's our Public Assistance cost
allocation plan it's several hundred
pages long
um and we use a variety of mechanisms to
track individuals time that is not you
now we don't track that like within the
state uh timekeeping system we have to
do that separately we have hundreds of
job numbers that we use to tie specific
sources of funds to specific uses and
and there's a pretty complex behind the
scenes system that we use to capture
that in order to leverage as many
federal dollars as we can I can
certainly share that that um the the the
approved the pay cap with you if you'd
like it
you know I I think I think there's
enough interest in the project
accounting of personnel time that I'd
like to add it as a special topic to
have you come back on someday but I I
want to I don't think that it's critical
to the immediate budget work that we're
doing it's more of a a good background
item and and and when we do crossover I
don't know if the Senate keeps you as
busy as we do
if they keep you as busy as we do then
we'll we'll figure out when we can do it
but but I think I would like a special
session on that
okay the Senate phase is is challenging
as well
so even if it were in January you know
we could we we could wait I just think
that's a good special topic that we
ought to understand better sure all
right
okay so Mr Wieters you really are
excuse now so thank you again appreciate
it run yeah and don't don't sit down in
here
all right uh where were we on 254 before
I interrupted
well if you're done with 254
um no I think I just wanted a definition
so what's what's the stew it
appropriates a million dollars each year
in general funds
[Music]
how did how did this is this the
governor's hb2 proposal or did this come
from somewhere else this past
legislative session SB 444 had
appropriated a million dollars for
Family Resource Centers
um in state fiscal year 23 as a
um consequently we
we requested to continue to fund that at
the same level
it's an existing account do do you have
what patreon
um I don't know what page it is but it's
account number 7216 and hb1 if I'm not
mistaken
that's that that's the kinship Grant
um account within the Bureau of family
assistance
that I have the account number right is
that correct
I I would need to go back and verify
that the the amounts don't don't show up
there but it's not clear to me whether
it's showing up in the adjusted
authorize it wouldn't appear to be
do you have any issues with this are you
are you comfortable with the h32
representative Northern are you
comfortable with this hp2 yes all right
okay so next
255.
yeah
is this the same thing as Meals on
Wheels
I I I I see nutrition in transportation
services and then I get emails talking
about Meals on Wheels is this are these
the same thing yes this would support
those contracts
so so the allegation in the emails is
generally that were funding Meals on
Wheels at a lower rate than we did in
the current year
is that true
if we approve this if we approve what's
in HP one
so if you approve this
um this hb2 appropriation here that
would give us funds sufficient to
maintain current service levels and
rates can you take us to the page number
where these are at because I think I
found them once and there were two line
items and it looked like uh from 23 they
were flat in hb1 for 24 and 25.
foreign
just so you know I have a hard break at
noon and we'll take a recess at noon for
a while uh oh I see a grimace
are we going to come back yeah it's a
recess we'll come back from one to two
or I you know I I only need 30 minutes
at noon uh if you guys want longer than
30 minutes then we can come back along
you know later
30 minutes is fine okay
we're
okay
foreign
yeah if you
um
sorry I'm in the wrong document here
so it is
account seven eight seven two
and that is on page
all right so that's on page 927.
and the class lines that you're
referring to representative erwort
Edwards
um is 541 and 544
um we we actually submitted a change
request that I believe Kevin has
um to to con to combine the home
delivered into the home delivered in
congregate because currently
um we we pay the home delivered meals
out of both lines
okay so you're you're proposing
541 and 544 get merged into one line
into 541 correct
okay
um
okay so so
this is uh so the observation that
the the governor's recommended budget is
flat relative to 23 is accurate
and then this 3.4 million a year in hb2
this is in addition to a base of of the
um
5.5 million so so now we're talking
about 9 million or so total per year
um there are a few other
class lines there's a few other accounts
that we pay for
for Meals on Wheels out of
um
would it be more effective if I get a
listing of those accounts the total
dollars and get that get that to you in
in detail or I can go through this here
now it may take me a couple minutes I
think that would help me because of the
direct questions and allegations that
we've we're cutting money and
um and and so I'd like to I'd like to
understand the allegation we'll go ahead
I might have a explanation for that okay
is it possible that arpa slash covid
funds during this current biennium have
been used in this account on top of the
what's currently in the budget for H for
our current biennium yeah so we um we
had utilized arpa funds for for a uh a
rate
increase during during the the the the
current biennium and and so these funds
are meant to replace that representative
Wallner had previously asked about what
are the areas where we were using arpa
funds and now we're using general funds
this and Hampstead are the two primary
areas
any other comments go ahead
representative thank you I just remember
when we were discussing this division
that there were Meals on Wheels line
items sort of all over the place like
four different can you just give me a 30
second explanation of why that is is it
because oops sorry it's because of that
they
have different
um deliverers or or so so we try to what
we do um we call them braided or Blended
contracts where we use multiple funding
sources
um and in our accounts we you know
sometimes it's a hundred percent federal
funds so we may account for like ssbg
funds in one account another account we
may
um have a maybe a 50 50 match another
account maybe 100 General funds and what
we do
um when we enter into a contract we try
to leverage as many of those funds and
those dollars that are allowable into
that single contract so what the
governor and executive Council will see
is they'll see a request enter into a
contract and then underneath it they'll
see the accounting detail and they'll
see all four or five or six accounts
that feed into that total price
limitation okay that makes sense thank
you
okay so um if if we do this hb2 item for
3.4 million what what is the federal
match that would be going with that
I believe it would be 50 50 but let me
verify let me put together a document
for the committee that that has all of
the the detail here and then the other
question of the day is um
why aren't we just showing this in hb1
if we expect this to be an ongoing
expense every year
we submitted this as a prioritized needs
request originally
because it was new
because it was new or because the
increment was new I I'm confused by the
term new I apologize because the
increase was it was over the three
percent so again when we submitted our
budget for say fiscal year 24 we had to
fit all of our general funds within a
three percent increase over over the 23
adjusted authorized okay all right did
you have a question
any questions on the right nope the left
is ready the right is ready
iron line is clear
all right
um
I I I think I'm ready to talk about 256.
okay 256 appropriates funds to increase
foster care rates
okay if we were to convert this to a
percentage what percentage are we using
to increase
in general and then is do we also have a
sense of what that does it's sort of an
individual family rate a percentage
increase or so so we had based this
request on the median Inc income
household it was previously on on the
low income household
um I can I don't have that figure
available but I can get that to you and
and the um this request was made to try
to make those rates more consistent and
um I don't think competitive is a right
word but perhaps more consistent with
the individuals that that are
participating in foster care
did did we get a briefing that I'm just
forgetting or maybe I skipped over the
page that said how many foster care
families were currently serving how many
uh cases are being unmet or wait listed
and and what what the typical
reimbursement rates are for those foster
families that feels like a graphic that
we should have had
I can check what Joe provided you and he
presented for the division for children
youth and families but I don't recall an
explicit conversation on that because if
we had a graphic like that then I would
just come back and and say can we can we
put this hb2 into context of that so
that we can see how much what percent
particularly the percentage if if we're
going if we're going to be looking for
other Medicaid procedure codes and I
know this is not a Medicaid procedure
code I get that but I think if we're
going to try to raise some rates
anywhere we need to understand
you know
what kind of percentage we're
comfortable with
go ahead you know I'm looking at page 14
of the oh I'm looking at page 14 on the
dcyf uh director's office
um
briefing book I guess they have foster
care includes license relative
placements
projected
and they've foster care in residential
were broken out so out through 2025
and Source through TANF and title IV but
you know we're looking at um
um you know foster care average cost per
case it's saying
uh residential it's 59 000 in
2024 so I'm guessing that number is
before this adjustment and we're looking
at uh
total of 482
individuals
so
um
I don't know if that helps it does
what's your conclusion what what do you
get a sense of a percentage increase
that we're dealing with
uh looks like 20 maybe
20 percent that above the 59 000 okay it
says budget 49953
um
and says average cost per case maybe
it's just
sorry you know trying to read and
move the book move the microphone move
my head
something uh so
I I guess I'm not not sure what
percentage increase so I think we can
come off a subject unless there are
other questions because I think Mr White
you're going to try to re-summarize this
so that we have
kind of kind of some backing to put 256
into context
all right
um
any other questions when that's got a
257.
section 257 this is the 17 million per
year of General funds to increase
Medicaid provider rates is this is this
when we say it's the 3.1 percent is that
this
it is this although the section itself
does not reference a specific rate
increase but yes but but that's how we
got to 17 million this is basically 3.1
percent
Okay so
um
representative Stringham while you were
out we committed you to talking tomorrow
to tell us what
progress you have been able to make
towards identifying what kind of
um procedure codes we might be looking
at and what kind of
potential rate adjustments that we could
make on a limited targeted basis
well you know I'm happy to talk at any
time that's that's why I'm here the
um but um
uh
you know there's way ways to look at
these things the primary way I think
that we need to look at things is that
the kind of the more Global level like
each separate fee schedule is maybe
being prioritized one over another
perhaps on on the impact of overall care
um
you know we we did look uh have have uh
some fee schedules brought in
um with like the physician fee schedule
and for example they listed the top uh
80 build codes and for those that about
half of them have have a good
comparative value which might be
Medicare
and you know half of them don't there's
services that are not provided under the
Medicare benefits program and
um
you know I think part of the part of the
discussion was that uh
uh that there are some services that
seem to be short and seem to be
dramatically below the Medicare
Benchmark rate you know if we had to
start from scratch uh forever you know
the Medicare rates which are highly
um
vetted the the process is to reset
Medicare physician fee schedules and
Hospital outpatient and Ambulatory
Surgery centers and inpatient rates are
are
are quite extensive and um
and at least some some of the things in
here seem seem a little bit random as
random as having a 3.1 percent increase
which from everything you know now now a
couple of weeks into this everything
I've heard it just seems like it was a
dart on a dartboard is anybody here
anything any different than that
okay yes
I I've I've heard that they've been
throwing darts at this for over a decade
and and that just like when you're
wandering in the woods if you're if your
asthma is off just a little bit by the
time you get
you know 10 miles out you're really far
from where you want to be I think that's
sort of what's happened and I think the
department is committed to spending the
next year trying to do a holistic
reset on Medicaid recommendations on
what their rates ought to be
what what we what what I thought that we
were all aligned on doing was to see if
there are some particular rates that are
are critical that really need to be
adjusted and fixed in this budget and
although it's not a hundred percent it's
probably just a kind of a a quick and
dirty thing because of the time and
expertise involved that something is
better than nothing if there are a few
things that we think are in crisis that
we can reach in and try to you know
reduce the chaos that would be good and
that's and that's sort of what I'm
hoping to get from you if if uh but
you're the expert so I'm looking forward
to whatever you have to present us
tomorrow okay that's
Mr Anon Anan
I I think this is one of the major
topics you you've been listening and
tracking is there anything for the good
of the division that you want to share
with us
you don't you don't have to move Mr
White just just come come on up I'd love
to hear what you have to say
good morning Stephen and president
Hospital Association uh for the record
um so we've been obviously following
this discussion relative to Medicaid
rates uh for a while Medicaid rate
Medicaid has historically paid
significantly less than the cost of
providing care New Hampshire's Medicaid
rates have often been some of the lowest
in the country
um we've been very appreciative of the
rate increase that was Institute a
couple years ago we were appreciative of
the rate increase that was provided to
birthing Services uh last year
this year what we are advocating is we
appreciate the governors across the
board rate increase suggestion
um but we don't believe that is what is
necessary at this time and are focusing
are in our efforts to
Medicaid rate increases for Behavioral
Health Services as well as post-acute
services like long-term care skilled
nursing facilities Home and Community
Services those are two of the areas that
we're having the most difficulty right
now getting patients out of a hospital
patients who don't need to be in the
hospital particularly those who you know
have been medically cleared and are
ready to go to their next level of care
we can't get them out because those
other facilities don't have the staff to
be able to accept those patients so a
more robust uh you know Medicaid rate
for those providers would give them the
predictability to be able to know that
they can hire those staff to serve those
patients so from our perspective we
think you know much more targeted rate
increases in those particular areas are
what is called for at this time not I'm
not asking for rate increases for
hospitals at this time because again the
most important thing we can do is help
the system move the patient to the best
place where they can get the care that
they need
that's completely consistent with what
we've heard from the New Hampshire
hospital for example the the that their
issue is there's nowhere to send a
patient upon discharge and so you're
having that same problem so you'd
recommend we try to mitigate that
bottleneck absolutely
are there are there any questions here
are you willing to take questions I I
just asked you up I don't I'm happy to
do so all right
um so what's the financial impact on a
hospital of having a patient they can't
discharge
um continue to collect funds above costs
below costs or none at all so um when a
patient is no longer
receiving a medically necessary service
in the hospital they're no longer being
reimbursed for that
um under Medicare we get paid a drg we
get so we get paid a set amount for a
certain procedure whether that patient
stays in there four days or 40 days or
400 Days we're getting the same payment
rate so it's really you know a
significant challenge because obviously
you can't
discharge them to another location for
the care that they need you can't bring
another patient in who needs that level
of care and obviously
um you know that's a patient that you're
not receiving reimbursement for so it's
a significant implication for for
hospitals
are there Senate bills that are going
through the present time that would
address the particular rates you're
talking about here so there are Senate
bill um 86 as well as Senate Bill 36 um
or two bills that we are following and
working closely with folks on that side
of the the the the capital
um and uh obviously
work over here in the house and so we
understand where things are here but yes
we are working those two bills over
there
I'm not familiar with those what what do
those do to do and are they redundant
with what you you represent or do you
think they're redundant with what I've
been asking representative Stringham to
look at
I can't speak to that I can't even speak
to what these do I just know I've heard
these mentioned before in similar
context I just bringing that up again
and actually I might suggest I mean
obviously if he could provide particular
rates that'd be very helpful also I
think Mr lippman is a guy to ask as well
in terms of your question about which
ones are the most critical I think he
and the hospital Association and others
and that of that knowledge base are the
would be good ones to ask you know you
know I have asked Mr Lipman and I don't
know what the status of his response is
do you miss Roy do you know he'll be
here tomorrow morning
um to to talk Medicare rates and hold an
answer for you then
okay
in terms of Representative Waller I
wondered um if other people had seen the
email from Jim Monahan
it went to all of us
did other people not see it
okay yeah he has he he huh what's the
summary can you can you give us it was
it was
um
can I sort of an outline that I think it
might be used in um
Senate Bill 86 of sort of a summary of
rate and rate increases that were being
suggested in that bill is your sense
that we're doing something redundant
that the Senate has taken on as a
specific project by asking
representative Stringham to put together
a special list for us of things that we
could hit in hb2 I I don't I don't know
when you just walked in but but I I if
if the Senate is addressing what I
thought we were going to try to address
in terms of identifying some procedures
that were particular underwater that
were creating substantial risks then
I I think it would be really
good for this committee to hear from Mr
Monahan and from the people who've
worked on that summary of um rate
increases and I think because they have
reasons for why they're suggesting
certain rate increases
um I wonder if uh this does anyone have
them on their bat phone that we could
call and ask them to come in tomorrow
any anyone in that kind of coordination
I could ask him to come in tomorrow all
right thank you
um so just to summarize he he sent us a
spreadsheet with about 13 rate
categories uh things like a nursing Aid
and uh they have recommendations with no
no real description of of uh of the
rationale for it but they do have a
specific list that they think would be
helpful to the Medicaid Program so I
think it would be great to hear from
them so did to as you looked at that
list and you've been thinking about this
sort of independently and getting some
other feedback did the items on the list
look familiar like there's a consistent
theme or was it something totally
different to quote Monty Python uh
I would say it's it's closer to the
latter because uh they they you can't
necessarily even tell which fee schedule
they fit under you know an individual
server service item so
okay do you have comments questions
nope
all right well uh I thank you very much
I appreciate you just willing to come up
and talk to us with this sort of
Engagement with the community it just
makes it a lot easier for us to get
closer to being right when we get done
so thank you
um I think we're at 276 oh no that's an
attorney general is that us that's not
us
or not it is not the next sex the next
section is 282 and 283 on page 89 and
those amend statutory requirements for
hospitals applying for designation as
receiving facilities
so 282 and 283. did we talk about this
these uh just briefly the other day when
I asked the opinion of the hospital
Association and we had the discussion
that this is probably
inappropriate
my conclusion was that this is sort of
inappropriate because we're we're
directing
the hospitals
to allocate their private resources to a
particular clinical priority that we
have but given our Workforce issues
they're going to have to rob Peter to
pay Paul and so in trying to solve a
problem we're going to likely create a
different problem that that's my summary
of what we heard in testimony
representative I just had a question for
the representative from the hospitals
possibly which is if you're well if you
interested in coming up I think we have
some more questions
if you could remind us
what
the timeline is that we're talking about
in terms of the Court's requesting a
solution for this problem and it was my
understanding that perhaps
the deadline for that solution was going
to come before our work was done here so
I'm just wondering if you could explain
that again
um so again Steven Hospital Association
president
um the court did uh issue their order on
February 23rd
um and gave the parties uh the hospitals
in the state 30 days to come back
um with either a joint solution uh to uh
this issue or if not a joint solution
then separate uh potential solution so
sometime at the end of this month
um I haven't counted 30 days from the
23rd but sometime at the end of this
month
thank you
so so what do you think the implication
of that is representative that that we
don't need 282 or 283 because they're
going to be overcome by larger events or
you are you suggesting that we'll be
better informed on these two items when
we see the solution proposed
call me a pessimist
but I question if a agreeable solution
is going to come to light
with by that time of that 30 days
I don't know if there could be an
extension or a delay I guess I just
wanted to understand
that side and perhaps how hard they
might be working on a solution so that
we could then understand
if the need is um
as severe on our end to come up with
solution to try to decide if this is a
section
that we go to the mat for and not in
I don't know if that made any sense it
kind of does i i i i i i there's no
money associated with these two items
right Mr Ripple I don't see any money
this is simply
doing the work of a policy Committee in
hb2
without an explicit set of hearings to
consider all of the implications this is
an hb2
land grab
it's true that its policy and has no
money
I'm listening for your wisdom
well personally I would favor taking
these sections out I feel like the
hospital Association and the
administration have a job to do to get
together and
work out what works for both but to put
this in-house Bill too just seems like
an inappropriate place and it puts us
sort of in the middle
of a negotiation that we're really not
part of at this point and
um you know maybe they'll come back to
us
or to the Senate
um
once they come to an agreement with
something that they will need in House
Bill too
and the Senate would presumably put that
in and we would then either agree or not
agree but this doesn't it seems like
it's just not a good idea to have this
here
Mr chair
different rationale similar
comment there is no money associated
with this it is clearly more of a health
and human services
policy decision not a budget item
um it would be better in my opinion that
a non-germaine amendment to another bill
going through HHS here if you're going
to do this do it that way as opposed to
railroading this through on a budget so
I'm I'm willing to take it out so so I'm
a little slow on the uptake because I I
have recently become aware that I think
it was division one
sent over to e DNA all of the oplc part
of hp2 for them to take a look at I
wonder if I should have sent these two
items over to HHS to see if they wanted
to come back with any kind of
recommendation on this
what are your thoughts on that
representative norgren or walner
yeah I would agree with that I mean
there's no money in it I mean there's no
reason we have to have an opinion on
this
so Mr Ripple I don't know how to I don't
know how to do that division one just
did it with Edna I don't know what the
procedure was to to pass the item over
to look for input but if we could do
something similar I would add it hey
representative Leon
my God your timing is good
so so we're talking about a couple hb2
items with no money associated with them
directing significant Health Care policy
from the governor's recommendation it's
statutory language I I would like to
send it over to HHS for you all to
consider from a policy perspective and I
I maybe give us some advice I don't know
what that looks like though Mr Ripple
was about to explain how division one
just did that the Edna
with Edna excuse me
a representative go ahead all we need to
do is delete them and then you can say
to the other committee could you please
have a look at these we don't need to
negotiate and bring it back to us
okay we
I learned that if you don't need to make
a decision right away you don't make the
decision right away
um so I don't know if why it would hurt
even though we're all predisposed to
killing these to get the times first but
you refer to division one that's what
they did they didn't say
go away and then give us back they said
here can you handle this and then the
committee said yes and they deleted them
from hb1 I literally don't know what
division one did that's why I was asking
Mr Ripple how they handled it yeah
and I and I don't know I haven't been
following what division one did with
this I believe in speaking with the
chair of Edna
um the licensure reform sections that
were in hb2 are going
to go into her committee for discussion
because they're it there's lots of
things that that rats nest goes pretty
deep so her committee is doing the Deep
dive on that I don't know if they're
going to continue forward in hb2 I do
know speaking with the same chairman
chairwoman
um they have bills one of which we've
already passed on the house and another
which is coming forward to address all
of this
and it's been stripped out of HP one two
okay so that's the key thing that the
the analogy here is they just division
one deleted it from hb2 and gave it to
Edna for their purposes in in
furtherance of that right you like
delaying decisions I'm out of the favor
of good decision bad decision no
decision
um my recommendation I'm not saying
you're wrong but my recommendation would
be we deleted out of hb2 the Senate can
always add it in there's lots of room if
they want to but if we delete it out of
hb2 and and ask
um HHS to take a look at this we would
have a house position on this by the
time we get to a committee of conference
all right so I think we're maybe a near
violent agreement that 282 and 283 ought
to come out of hb2
and and we could somehow let
representative Leone and her committee
know that they may want to look at this
okay which takes us to 284. 284 which is
a related subject so I'm not sure if you
want to address that the same way or not
right
yes
somebody whispered yes in my ear
so yes
yeah thank you
all right so do we have any more
questions for the hospital Association
because I'm I'm ready to recess this for
at least 30 minutes did we just say that
that last section 284 was also going to
be on the Strip list I I think so yes
because it's the same logic
okay all right uh thank you thank you so
much for your flexibility and your input
appreciate it uh Mr White I I think
we're going to recess uh for a while
and we're going to come back and we're
going to talk about uh a sheet that Mr
Ripple put together for us and I'm I'm
not sure where that sheet is but
if you want to tell us what we're going
to do when we come back yeah I'm not
sure you have a copy of it but I have a
few documents for you one of which is a
list of HHS change requests and
accompanying detail so I'm hoping you
can talk through that this afternoon and
I've also prepared
tracking sheets of the committee's
actions on House Bill one and House Bill
2. there are no actions yet but there
will be so each day I hope to update
this with what you have done so I'll be
providing this daily
and so I'll give you copies for those to
look at when you come back to
okay I I'm I'm gonna do 30 minutes does
anyone want more than 30 minutes
I'm I'm going to recess division three
until uh 12 45.
thank you
we are out of recess at 12 45.
um
while we were away I I got word from
the speaker's office that uh we need to
reschedule tomorrow
um so all of the hard preparation all
the coordination and of inviting
external parties
we need to reschedule because of the
pending snowmageddon
so so that's uh that's one thing
how will that affect
our full uh executive session we're
having on Wednesday well that's a
excellent segue thanks and that's this
piece of paper right here
so what we were going to do tomorrow at
one o'clock is we were going to have
technically all we do are work sessions
we don't really ever have an exact
session
so I'm gonna I'm gonna say this
so that Mr Ripple can correct me if I'm
wrong
is the only Bill that we have to decide
on is HB 527 because it was an early
Bill and we've got to get rid of it we
have four other bills where we were the
second committee so we have more time
but because
we do work sessions
I don't even know that our
making a recommendation and sending it
to the full finance committee needs to
be in the calendar
and so I'm asking Mr let me ask it this
way in a declarative statement
I think if the minority
if representative norgren agrees I think
we could just vote on HB 527 now to give
our recommendation to the full finance
committee and not worry about coming in
early Wednesday because that's the
alternative well we have a quorum
I think we do have a quorum but I want
to hear am I allowed to have a work
session vote on 5 27. I'll put it this
way division two has done exactly that
they've taken up bills that were noticed
purely as a budget work session now
representative hole said that he was
going to be a little bit late
representative erf is in the other room
um so would you would you go get
representative Earth since he's he's
available and tell him we're about to
vote
yeah we were just so Janet usually gives
me a sheet with a vote to do a vote
tally could you could you see if you
could grab one thanks
no I didn't actually wait though
representative norgren are you okay if
we just go ahead and vote on just HP 527
um
yeah so representative Mooney was
looking for you we're getting ready to
do a vote
oh did she find you or did you find her
there she is
okay
oh and then also representative Weiler
I'm so sorry he he has asked me that
anytime we vote that I invite him yeah
I I don't I don't think it'll matter uh
we're at 5 27. uh Medicaid reimbursement
rates for certain assisted living
facilities
I I don't think his vote will matter but
his request to invite him stands
I'm just looking at the clerk's addendum
for the calendar
um there is a scheduled division work
session does that did you were you
already aware of that for this very bill
for tomorrow we had a 10 o'clock work
session and then at one o'clock we had
five bills the house clerk sent an
addendum for Wednesday and has us having
a 527 work session at 9 45 a.m
yes because I just agree that's what
you're talking about we would have had
to do it earlier on Wednesday right okay
sorry just making sure you saw this so
if we do this now
that obviates the 945 I mean I'll still
come in because it's been calendared now
and open and close it but
um but I I think we could just give you
guys some extra time to come in
representative walner
I I guess now okay I think this is like
a murder mystery one one person leaves
never to be seen again
but we can't we can't go on without him
so uh
I think he's getting his sheet
so so uh Mr chair what what we're doing
is we're just advancing our vote on 527.
uh I I think we've discussed it a few
times and I since we have some consensus
okay
so
um division three work session on HB 527
I would entertain a motion to itl anyone
making that motion
I would also entertain a motion to
retain
Mr chair I would make a motion to retain
is there a second second second
okay so the motion is made and seconded
to retain house bill 527.
is there any discussion
discussion about Medicaid rates
for all these providers and it seems
like everybody should get it would make
it at least for me it would make it much
clearer if I would be able to talk about
all of them at the same time
is there any other conversation the
motion right the Russian for retain
makes perfect sense because if we have
any cleanup to do after we get through
all of the Medicaid rate changes via the
budget we have a bill in Play to work
with and we can
use it that way
any further conversation go ahead
represent Mooney
thank you Mr chairman
orders the bill is certainly well
intentioned we heard some from some we
heard from some great speakers who of
care very deeply about this subject
matter and have run their own homes have
or are currently running their own homes
however it is very clear that the
original language of this bill is
incorrect on many levels for example
there's no real definition for a quote
unquote small assisted living facilities
now the sponsors of the bill did put
forth an amendment in good faith it was
a certainly a well amended change to the
original language but there were still
some holes there for example they
referenced only 804 licenses turns out
it could also apply to 805. so very
clear that the bill needs work both in
its original and proposed amended form
also came to our attention that there's
a Senate Bill 86 that is going to be
examining exactly the subject matter
plus we have a budget so for that reason
I'll be voting retain thank you I I
appreciate that summary I'm sure the
sponsor of the bill will as well
um now this was an early Bill does that
somebody remind me does that mean it
bypassed uh HHS in the house and came
straight to us I believe it did
okay so so there's a policy issue in
here that the policy committee hasn't uh
heard so representative hole on a
tangent I just saw an email from the
clerk I don't know whether you guys
discussed it all business tomorrow has
been canceled and stuff moved to
Wednesday we we discussed that while you
were away and and also we did some
birthday party planning and but yeah yes
we got that
all right so uh representative Weiler
the public needs to understand
that the Medicaid rates for a nursing
home
are not affordable by any nursing home
the only way it works like in the county
home is the property taxpayers are
making up the difference and and I was
also involved with the Masonic Home
where we were up we could afford up to
20 percent uh Medicaid but that was only
because all the Masons were expected to
send in checks to that home every year
so people need to understand if if they
need to go to a nursing home they're
lucky to find a spot if all they've got
to support them is Medicaid thank you
is there any other discussion
not seeing any discussion
um Mr clerk would you call the role
plays uh yes on House Bill
527 the motion is to retain
um
representative Mooney yes
uh representative erf
yeah yes
representative hole yes
representative walner
representative in Oregon yes
representative tolersky yes and
the the clerk votes yes
representative Weiler yes chairman one
and uh and chairman Edwards uh yes
okay the vote is nine nine to zero I do
have a question
um uh is
um
does this now go stay in and finance
three
as a retained Bill and then and it does
not need to be confirmed by the full
finance committee that it's retained so
there's no committee report it just goes
on a list of retained bills okay thank
you but doesn't
the full committee need to
confirm it
doesn't who the full committee the full
finance committee yes
so there will be a full finance
committee vote on whether or not to
accept our recommendation to retain
it'll be on Wednesday thank you
are there any other questions on on that
there there are other there are still
four bills that we have that were second
committee bills so we have more time
um
we don't need to do those today I don't
think we should but we do need to
reschedule them do you have any thoughts
on rescheduling those
particularly given that we just lost
tomorrow
what 29 is scheduled for Wednesday
morning
I think you need 49 sununo 49 thank you
I would uh
I would reschedule these to
possibly late next week I think the
committee should really address all of
its budget work before it gets back to
the bills
I I do think that's the right priority
foreign
[Music]
agreement I'll stop asking then
uh
all right
um
then
what are we working on now Mr Ripple the
sheet that she just gave us so I've
handed out a packet and
at the front is a summary sheet and
these are all hold on a second Mr
Williams
did you have something did were you here
for a reason that we just disappointed
you on or what's going on with you
all right thanks
so you have a summary sheet containing
all of the Department's requests of
division three
and I've taken the liberty of breaking
these out uh a bit differently than the
department may have on the first page
you have technical requests
and I consider these technical because
they do not add General funds they do
not add permanent full-time positions
they're things like acceptance of
Federal grant money that wasn't budgeted
their movement of funds between Class
Lines within an accounting unit so to my
mind at least these are all purely
Technical and if anyone sees anything
here that they they disagree with that
assessment by all means feel free to
take it off but my Hope was that the
division could vote on these as a block
everything that's on the first page of
this summary sheet
on the second page
let's do this one page at a time so so
people should be looking at the front
page the technical request total I I do
because I my eyes aren't that good to
read the description right off the way
so this is a tobacco one what are we
doing with the tobacco one
line item two
this is a carry forward of federal funds
and Nathan would be in a better position
than I am to discuss the details I'm
sure you just answered it okay
representative norgren do you think you
all will be comfortable just having us
take a Voice vote on whether or not we
want to accept these technical request
changes
if you want to just end intake now and
caucus and we'll vote later that's okay
I just I I'd like to be able to move on
things we can move on is this thousands
and thousands
those are actual dollars so the general
fund decreases literally twenty five
thousand eight hundred eighty two okay
it's not talking about a lot of money
here
so the second page has prioritized needs
and others so I'd like to see if we're
okay on the front page under technical
requests and just accepting these
representative hole
um I was going to take line 14 which was
an obvious one if the department right
is not moving forward with a contractor
initiative to the tune of almost three
hundred thousand dollars
um
that's an easy one that I think we could
all quickly get behind
so you accepted as written on the
document
yes
okay what I think we're trying to do is
to see if we can accept the entire front
page all line items all one vote
representative walner
accept all of the front page
as it is written
all right let's uh let's do this on a
show of hands on page one uh all 15 line
items on the technical request sheet
raise your hands if you're in favor of
passing it along
any opposed representative poll you
don't get to abstain
since I don't understand all of them
I'll oppose but I'm okay with it passing
so so eight eight to one I think we can
we can go to the second page now now
what would you like to do with this Mr
Ripple the prioritize needs how do you
want to talk about it well I think it
might be best for the committee to have
Nathan address the prioritize needs
items as you can see here the dollars
are a lot greater
um and these are prioritized needs that
were not included in the governor's
budget and I believe these are
the ones that were discussed
throughout the meetings that the
committee has had you've asked questions
about certain certain areas and whether
the department had prioritized needs in
those areas and
they're presented here
so so what I what I would propose doing
representative nordgren is
um if if there's any further questions
on the prioritized need maybe we could
ask them now uh otherwise not do
anything more than ask questions and
then you we can each caucus and come
back in our next meeting to to talk
about what we want to do with each of
these that's my proposal what do you
think
I can't hear you
um I just had a question on
um 19 prioritized needs state phase down
to
uh
yes
line 19 could you maybe just comment
Nathan white Chief finance officer
Department of Health and Human Services
um representing representative norgren
just to clarify uh the second page line
19 the state face down
yes okay
um sure so in the current biennium
um we have been under budgeted
in this in this particular line
we had submitted a prioritized needs
request during the governor's phase that
was not funded to to uh to cover these
costs we've had to transfer funds from
from elsewhere within within the
department to to cover these costs and
um these are these are essentially
dollars that we pay to the federal
government to support the Medicare Part
D insurance premium payments for dual
eligible individuals so individuals that
are eligible for Medicaid and Medicare
um this I'll I'll pause there
okay thank you
yep you're good are the as I'm looking
at these
um there's others here that feel like
I'm looking at them for the first time
but uh but that's just the way my memory
works you have a question representative
I do
um line 21 system of care that's a big
chunk of
um money
can you explain what the children's
residential treatment rate is and just
where that is in the grander scheme of
things sure so
um
when when dcyf division for children
youth and families came in and then I
believe Katia Fox as well during for the
division of Behavioral Health
um had had referenced this this
prioritize need
last year we entered into contracts with
the residential rate providers
previously we had paid them through
through other mechanisms but during that
process we established rates
um with with all these providers it has
since been determined that those rates
are not sufficient to cover their actual
costs incurred so we went and look at
their we looked at everyone's costs as
far as what they reported and determined
additional funds are needed to for those
contracts okay I think I've missed that
part of the presentation so I apologize
representing walner
so remind me on that same line what it
what are the federal funds
or that in in the system of Caroline yes
um though there's a mix of funding there
and and so part of the part of the cost
is dependent upon the individual child
um so Medicaid would would play a a
major role within that line
I guess my question would be
uh we've been talking about Medicaid
rates
this morning and we're actually going to
have a Time
coming up here that we're going to talk
about Medicaid rates
and wouldn't this be
better to have it discussed with that
that group of other Medicaid rate
increases that we're we may look at
I believe I misspoke that now I'm
thinking about how that particular
contract Works um
let me follow up with you because
there's three separate funding sources
within that contract and the Medicaid
dollars
let me verify that those would actually
show up here I don't believe they would
now that I'm thinking about it I believe
they're a budget out of another account
but let me get that detail for you okay
so you're going to tell us what the if
it's not Medicaid I I really like to
know what these federal funds are of
course
all right and so the key word that
flagged all of that is under description
where we're talking about rates
treatment rates
so my simple way all of those rate
discussions on are in one bucket but
Mr chair
uh yes representative
Nathan yes is that section right
underline sections 2122 the same section
that also covered some of the child care
costs that's all that large increase was
that is that in the same
division so I remember and I don't have
the page in front of me where we were
going from ninety five hundred dollars
for child care for 3 100 families or
something up to 11
000 in child care expenses is that the
same section or is that different no no
this is entirely different okay thank
you
representative Waller thank you so on
pay on line 20.
that is
[Music]
um
when I read the description I thought it
was interesting it's about uh
stabilization services
and in locations around the state
and I was just reading about other
states
who actually have crisis
stabilization centers I mean I read
something about Tennessee I read
something about Massachusetts
where instead of using emergency rooms
people are actually using
these Sinners or mental health centers
is this in is this what we're talking
about is it similar
what are we talking about here
I I my understanding is yes
um but but I can have Katya fox come
down and speak a little bit more
specifically to this
um because because this is this is part
of the 10-year mental health plan
if if you'd like her to come down to
speak to that
you know
talk to me
doesn't have to be here yeah I you know
I'm looking at these and and my memory
is just gone because I I the Hampstead
Hospital
I don't remember this extra
8.8 million to cover
quote projected expenses I I just don't
remember that
does anyone else remember going through
Hampstead Hospital and and seeing an 8
million 8.8 oh I'm sorry which one I'm
looking at the bottom one 23.
and it's uh 8.8 in the two years General
funds to cover projected expenses
that that feels like the very first time
for me
Mr White I actually I actually think
there's an error here the the the 24
should be zero
um the the 25 figure so we had spoken a
couple of times about some of the
challenges that we have there because we
don't have a lot of history behind the
expenses and the revenues and during the
governor's phase of the budget
um this the state fiscal year 2025 the
general funds were cut in half
um and what you're seeing there is our
request to add those back in just to
clarify
okay so 24 it says 4.4 million but you
think that should be zero correct
and in 25 this 20 the this 4.4 million
is kind of like an insurance policy
because we don't have the business
history and we we want to make sure that
we don't end up in a lost situation I
don't think I'd call an insurance policy
based on the trends that we're seeing
right now those those funds are required
um and uh once I get out of here I'll be
providing the committee with an
additional analysis this is just to show
you the expense and revenue that we've
had year to date what do you think 4.4
million is as a percentage of all
expenses
for Hampstead for handstead yeah
because is that as much as 10 percent
for reference in 24 it's currently a
budget this is an HP one it's currently
budgeted at 9.2 million in 24 and 4.7
and 25 so I think what this is doing and
bringing the 25 figure up
to the same level as the 24 figure 23 24
figure
that's what yes that is correct and then
and then okay
all right well thank you
okay so are there any line items here
that anyone wants to have
somebody come back and talk to us about
I wouldn't mind hearing more about the
system of care one in particular
system of care 2023 or 21 22 yeah
and I think all these should be
discussed in the context of what we want
to do with all kinds of things not just
with regard to what they want to do so
so let's how does this does this feel
like it'd work let's let's kind of table
these items
let's get through the core of our hb1
work
um these are not in none of these are in
hp2s these are all potential hb1
editions right
so so let's see if we can get through
our core
and um and then while we're getting
through our core if if if these come up
in that course of discussion we can have
that sidebar
and if
and otherwise we could we could hold
these to the end does that make sense
you're looking at me like that doesn't
make sense Representative no
I'm still working out the process and
how this all plays out so it's fine
could I ask a question well that that
kind of makes sense to you let's sort of
postpone these all right could I ask a
question yesterday line 27 before we do
this yeah uh we're not on 27 yet okay
I'm still on the piano okay fine fine
okay so does that make sense to you Mr
Ripple because you're really the one
that's managing and juggling all this
behind the scenes it does make sense and
I did not expect you to take any votes
on the prioritized needs today that's
one reason I separated everything out
this way yeah okay well I was genius on
your part then so
um do you want to lead us in a
conversation then what an other is Right
other is sort of a catch-all category
that I created here and the items in the
other category either add General funds
or they convert temporary positions to
full-time positions
or their accounting units that are of
particular interest to individual
division members mainly I included the
other category by taking out items from
the technical category that I thought
might hold up your ability to vote on it
as a block
okay so I think fam is there a question
you gave me a hand movement okay
see you got me trained out of the corner
of my eye I see you okay so I think line
item 25 is the Family Planning money uh
I think this was uh probably put in
there because I've shown interest in
this line before
Mr chair yeah I actually sent Mr Ripple
a whole different set of numbers for
this one Have you shared that yet with
uh Mr White
no I haven't okay so yeah there's
definitely some work to be done on that
one for sure a lot more than what's here
okay so so I just want to um say the
part that I remember and and see if it's
included in this number or not we in in
the previous budget we uh allotted fifty
thousand dollars which basically worked
out to up to five grants of ten thousand
each for new vendors as an incentive to
to bid on the family planning
this time when we talked about it I ask
that we double that because not a single
person or not an entity rather had had
bid on Family Planning so so I wanted to
up the bonus pool to a hundred thousand
and a potential of 20 000 per
um successful contract awardee who's new
that that's what I remember is is a
hundred thousand that I mentioned in
that meeting is that part of the 984 and
and I'm not assuming that anyone else
agrees with it I'm just trying to make
sure I understand that number
do you know well my answer would be I
believe this is just correcting what
they got wrong with what's in the basic
budget and that that in itself needs a
correction and then once that's all done
we need to discuss what you just brought
up on top of all that
okay
so that has to be deferred anyways
all right
um so represent represent an order did
you have a representative
so this shows this numbers going down so
savings to the budget right and
it's federal funds but yes
um
it's just money we haven't been able to
spend or because we haven't been able to
contact no it's an incorrect um
just incorrect budgeting basically and
it's still incorrect
we'll get it right
representative Wallner
so when I see
um
on line 27 the sununu center
um allocation here that is also in house
bill
house bill 2. so basically we're just
moving the funds from house bill to over
to House Bill one
but we were going to have some
deeper information about the lines that
would go on is that correct yes it's it
just came through my email so I'll be 40
minutes
thank you
okay on who I representative Weiler
so online
19.
um
dual eligible individuals
if they're eligible twice why do we need
more money only one one time would they
need to be paid for
so I this Dells are pretty deep into the
Medicaid Program
um I I think when Henry lippman comes
down here Whatever Whenever the next
rescheduled meeting is we can kind of
delve into that but this is basically
the amount that we have to pay back to
the federal government
um for these individuals
they collected twice
so so they they require that the state
pay them back a certain dollar figure to
offset their costs
yeah
I don't see the phrase dual eligible am
I missing it
yeah third line
there it is
do do all eligible Medicare usually pays
80 percent Medicaid 20 typically so
Medicare is paying first and then we pay
back Medicare I think that's what this
line item is referring to
yes it sounds right okay
um on the pdab
there's an hb2 item that goes with this
um
it's being heard as a an amendment to a
house bill in Commerce
this week I think
uh and and I would carry it over here it
basically the
the
pdab for those that don't remember the
acronym the prescription drug
affordability board
with the amendment being presented to
Commerce does
this is essentially just three things
in accordance with the gel car unanimous
recommendation it has the legislature
relooking the fee structure which seemed
to be contrary to the New Hampshire
Constitution that was sort of the advice
given to jailcar with the recommendation
that the legislature re-look at so so
the first thing it does is rather than
allowing them to have this fee structure
that really is a tax
we would just fund the pdab with General
funds
also because there was a lot of
testimony from activist groups saying
that the pdab was something really
worthwhile we created a dedicated fund
where
groups could contribute
towards the pdab mission
the the big contenders for that were new
Futures and the AARP
and then the third thing and I think the
third thing is really the biggest thing
of all is it eliminates
the ability of the pdab to Levy fines
the uh the finding Authority had no
check on it
the pdab could issue a data call of
their
stakeholders and the the data call
who didn't have to stand up to any sort
of principles or standards this could be
pretty minor I think the chairman of the
pdab gave us the example of whether or
not a portion of a vial was being put
back into stock they could ask about
that sort of level of detail if the
answer wasn't forthcoming they could
start finding them a thousand dollars a
day up to twenty five thousand so that
finding authorities seemed pretty
arbitrary and without a check and
balance on it so the Commerce Amendment
strips that
yes sir
it's 124. we're we're going to be right
behind you at two o'clock we want all
the committee members over in the
chamber to listen to the input from the
public and bring your name please
yeah well it wasn't my idea I got a note
uh okay so so the pdab
runs up also against
um
the the governor's portion of the hb2 I
don't know which division is looking at
it not us uh runs up against a new
um commission or something from the
governor
the the executive branch to to look at
regulatory reform looking for
opportunities to streamline so so so
there's a an amendment uh to hb2 being
drafted to have the the pdab participate
in that regulatory reform
effort to ensure that they don't have a
redundancy in there and there's several
opportunities for them to eliminate
redundancy so this dollar amount of
104 of other
would not be other
if if we accept the hb2 item or if the
Commerce bill passes it would not be
other because they won't be collecting
this from
third parties
it would become General funds to the
extent that we budgeted
and the amount that we budgeted is I
think something that we have yet to
discussed
discuss I'm thinking more of a seventy
five thousand dollar range for
a personal Consulting contract to give
them ability to go get some Manpower and
some extra money to pay for some extra
things but that would be a substantial
reduction in the half a million or so
that they're they're requesting so the
pdab
line item is going to be pretty
significant we probably ought to have
probably that that's a that's that's a
big discussion for us to get ready to
vote on
it's probably at least
an hour to schedule the pdab by itself
well I I'm seeing you looking away like
that was that's a horrible idea what do
you think
well I wouldn't schedule it individually
I would just take it up as part of a
larger budget work session
I
no I know I'm just saying within a work
session okay okay there's a block for
about an hour so the only uh the only
other thing I would mention is that with
tomorrow
out of the picture uh Wednesday is out
of the picture because you have a full
Finance exec session on several dozen
bills Thursday you have a house session
so you have Friday which currently I
believe the division scheduled to meet
at one I was going to ask you about
moving that up to the morning I I can
move earlier okay so you'll have Friday
and Monday
followed by potentially three full days
of house sessions I don't know what's
going to happen with next Tuesday so
when when's our drop dead date where we
have to give something to the full
finance committee
um well I'm supposed to tell you that
you need to have all your decisions done
by Monday but you could have them done
by Friday next Friday
so the real answer is Monday
and then I could go as late as Friday
without theoretically breaking things
yes but the three days of potential
house sessions
complicates all of that so it really
ought to be Monday
I think Monday is probably unrealistic I
would aim for Monday but I think you'll
probably end up having to use Friday
with Tuesday Wednesday Thursday possibly
out of the mix due to house sessions
correct
okay we'll aim for Monday
so we're almost done
what is that
um
so let's let's finish let's just make
sure we can come off of this sheet first
are there any other items there to be
discussed
each of these has sort of a sponsor
within the division three is that what
you implied with the other
um
they were categorized as other for any
number of reasons if there was any
amount of General funds included no
matter how small I put them in other
okay now 29 has no money what's what's
going on there I included that one
because it converts 21 temporary
positions to 21 full-time authorized
okay
so that's a change request that's why it
says change request
okay
if you go home and you start to look at
it and think about it and you have
questions send the questions to Mr
Ripple please
all right
any final comments before we end
discussion on the bigger sheet
okay uh what What's this multi-page
document spreadsheet this is just the
packet that contains the backup for
everything on the larger sheet so these
are all the detailed changes that will
be made in the budget for anything that
you adopt on this sheet and the only two
that are missing detail right now are
the sununu center which the department
will provide and one of the two
Hampstead Hospital items which they'll
also provide
and you have you are these on the LBA
site as well
not yet but I will post them this
afternoon thank you representative
Waller
just very quickly I just wanted to ask
Nathan on the um line 2122 the system of
care
that must be more than three percent
rate increase
or maybe it is three percent is it I I
can't answer that uh right off the top
of my head
um I know that those contracts are north
of 100 million dollars collectively
combined
um so I will have to get back to you on
that my assumption is yes
um but let me verify okay thank you
so I think we've covered everything we
can cover and we need to head over to
reps Hall if we're going to go do our
duties over there before we go are there
any comments or observations questions
anyone
remember Mr White uh what one um one
quick thing that that I I would ask
um the committee before Friday if you
can please let me know if there are any
specific and right now I'll plan to have
Henry here I'll plan to have Katie here
but if there are any other areas where
you want to delve into the details a
little bit please let me know and I'll
make sure that the division director is
here for those conversations
thank you you have anything else
Miss Europa you got something for us
before we go we're we're out Tuesday we
don't get any Governor's coffee tomorrow
I think representative representative
the potential for Friday morning if
that's a go and tonight if it's at 10
o'clock or okay so whatever I'm doing
Friday morning this is more important so
I'll I I can start as soon as possible
and I think we were reserving Friday
mornings because I usually had double
bookings so if I'm the only problem
let's start earlier okay does Friday at
nine work
um is there anyone here that does not or
should not start at 9 00 a.m due to
concern about travel on Friday 9 A.M no
issues
here in the on the campus so you want to
we can start at 9 30 Friday was that
enough time
9 30 Works 9 30 Friday I have a meeting
mid-morning but I can step out and
unless we're exacting
okay
last call anyone in the audience do you
have any final comments
all right so division three work session
is completed for the day thank you
take your name plate if you're going
over to Repsol